hey this is just uh the the best this is
another reminder
of how
all of these supposed principles of the
modern republican right
are meaningless to them they only care
about what is good for me right now as
you might remember
when we were getting closer to the 2020
election it was republicans united that
mail-in ballots are bad
mail-in ballots help democrats mail-in
ballots allow democrats to commit fraud
and on and on and on and in the
immediate aftermath of the 2020 election
it was republicans saying we've got to
stop the count or start the counter
count these correctly or that but the
point was the mail-in ballots are bad
for democracy they could be criminal
they are fraudulent and they just must
be stopped because that's that's what
the democrats do
well now
they are still counting ballots in the
pennsylvania republican senate primary
this was the race we covered live last
tuesday and which on wednesday i told
you
memit oz is just slightly ahead of dave
mccormick but they're still counting
ballots well now
democrat i'm sorry republicans
candidates and the parties are arguing
amongst themselves count the mail in
ballots don't count them include these
throw these out because they don't have
a date on them
they don't care about the principles all
they care about is what helps me right
now there's an article uh from the new
york times mccormick sues to count
undated mail-in ballots trailing oz in
pennsylvania senate race wait wait a
second hold on
so
in 2020 the problem was
any
irregular ballot like it doesn't have a
date on it or whatever the case may be
you've got to throw it out that's bad
stuff
now
the undated mail-in ballots are believed
to be likely good for dave mccormick and
not so good for amendment oh now we've
got to sue we'd better count those
mail-in ballots even if they don't have
a date as irregular as it is for the
ballot to not have a date written in we
must make sure that the will of the
voter is represented and that the vote
is counted but you guys were just
against that
david mccormick is trying to close the
gap against mehmet oz in the undecided
republican primary contest
in uh this is neil vigdor in the new
york times in a lawsuit filed monday in
pennsylvania the republican senate
candidate david mccormick demanded that
undated mail-in ballots should be
counted in his primary race against
celebrity physician mehmet oz whom he
trailed by less than a thousand votes
mccormick asked the court of
pennsylvania to allow election officials
in all 67 counties to accept mail-in
ballots from voters who turned them in
by the may 17 deadline but didn't write
the date on the outer return envelopes
that step is required by law one that
republicans have fought to preserve it's
been republi republicans in pennsylvania
and other states
who have argued for 2020
if there's no date written on the
outside
you put that in the trash
you cover it in
rocket fuel and you burn it we don't
count it but now all of a sudden
mccormick wants it counted
okay
um arguing
the ballots were indisputably submitted
on time
they were date stamped upon receipt
and no fraud or irregularity has been
alleged
hmm
in the mccormick campaign's lawsuit
uh mr hicks who is this uh lawyer
took the opposite view of mail-in
ballots saying the election boards in
allegheny county in western pennsylvania
and blair county have balked at counting
the undated ballots those counties he
said were delaying taking action until
after tuesday when they are required to
report unofficial results to the state
the board's refusal to count the ballots
at issue violates the protections of the
right to vote under the federal civil
rights act and pennsylvania constitution
whoa that's
that's pretty serious now you might
remember that the very same lawyer
was part of a group of lawyers that
trump hired to challenge mail-in ballots
in the 2020 election the same lawyer
now saying count all the ballots was
part of a group of lawyers saying don't
count them in november of 2020 when he
worked for donald trump uh as a reminder
here is dave mccormick on election night
saying hey you know what we've still got
mail-in ballots coming we might still be
able to win this thing
now we're gonna
we're gonna win this campaign we're
gonna win this campaign
and uh and tomorrow right now we have
tens of thousands
of mail-in ballots that have not been
counted right that are going to need to
be counted beginning tomorrow
and uh and so that's unfortunate we're
not going to have resolution tonight
okay so now mail-in ballots are good
what is the takeaway the takeaway these
people are pathetic they don't really
have principles it's whatever's good for
me whatever is good for me is the
principle we'll see ultimately who wins
this one but just remember this just
remember this when they start making all
sorts of claims about mail-in ballots in
november
monday memorial day we're doing our
one-day membership special make sure
you're on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
if you are you'll be notified monday
morning of how to take advantage of this
great one-day membership discount
if you're using traditional toilet paper
and paper towels you're probably cutting
down trees from north american old
growth forest and i've talked about
before we don't want to be doing that
also they come wrapped in single-use
plastic that's also a mess and the
solution is real paper this is a sponsor
i feel great about real paper makes
paper towels and toilet paper from fast
growing bamboo not from virgin tree
fibers from forests using bamboo
prevents soil erosion it prevents
habitat loss and importantly
it's a major impact on carbon real paper
also uses no plastic packaging so we
often talk about what can we do
corporations need to do many things but
what can we do to help the environment
this is an easy thing and i made the
switch to real paper at home i can't
tell the difference everybody buys
toilet paper everybody buys paper towels
this is one you can actually feel good
about and you can use the code pacman
for 30 off your first shipment when you
sign up for a subscription at
realpaper.com pacman the link is down
below